a perfect problem between lifting weight  scanning muscle and putting content out  and building a brand everybody wants to  just peek out as soon as they possibly  can they do a few reps a little bit of  volume and they try and Peak they try  and get their one right Max but the guys  should get the biggest and strongest  skill train for a year without peeking  out train for four years like Olympians  without peeking out and when you build a  base of a pyramid like that the peak is  so much higher so you got to build a  horizontally first before you go  vertical everyone goes inch wide and  then they go an inch up rather than a  mile wide and a mile up but it takes  time to build that base